welcome to this video yeah this is a new
video um doing the tactics trainer on
chess.com yeah um in earlier videos um I
went for different difficulty settings
and the last video I did was
2,600 which okay does not relate to the
feeder rating um but um I I decided to
go back to something a bit simpler also
to um yeah to adjust to the different
levels of play that the audience has so
this is 2,000 level again let's just do
this okay um while I fixed something
about the video at the timer started and
I had some chances to GL to to look at
the position um in passing and I think
this should be about the
efile yeah The Rook coming to E8 you
want to play Rook uh F2 E8 first but it
is not helping that much after Rook
takes d8 there is like Rook E8 Rook d8
Knight d8 Knight F6 check those kind of
ideas and what I think you need to do
here is to play this move to E8 so this
Rook to E8 and now you have F5 and you
will win the Knight now it's just a
matter of using the right Rook yeah okay
should take with the pawn and uh this
wasn't that difficult it's just um a
matter of taking the right Rook to set
up the deadly pin okay the next one
please oh that looks fairly dramatic
this position how does white win here H
okay yeah it looks very dangerous for
black here we are close to checkmating
uh black like Queen G7 or queen f8 made
is all hanging by a threat
the first move that comes to my mind is
Rook d8 here which threatens a ton
really a
ton uh the only thing that I'm wondering
is I mean Rook d8 is fairly U is fairly
straightforward Knight takes d8 this
queen takes f8 mate or queen G7 mate or
Rook d8 Rook takes d8 this queen takes
G7 check uh Queen takes F6 check King G8
and then Knight E7 Checkmate yeah or
sometimes Knight H6 Checkmate but at the
moment the queen here on F4 is covering
that the the move that I'm struggling
with is Rook d8 Queen C1
check a check I can go to
H2 check on
F4 it's no difference the captures are
no difference check on F4 King to H3
maybe yeah and then there is no check
check no I think Rook d8 should do the
trick check again yeah or this one this
is an easy one I can just take here and
then Knight takes this Rook takes f8
Checkmate so it's uh funny yeah this
kind of checkmate with the Knight and a
piece on the eighth rank a rook or a
knight very nice okay next
one
oh that looks that looks very
dangerous some combination here of
Bishop H6 Queen G6 things like
that um but how exactly is it done Queen
F6 looks uh very
strong but is it a
win Queen E6 is also looking strong H
okay but before I look into
this too deeply Let's uh think about it
a little bit first is there a way
to I mean there is no counterplay
really
H Queen F6 looks uh very very looks like
a very strong move
move I wonder if there is any defense to
that it really isn't right but what is
the difference is there a
difference between that and queen
G6 Queen G6 that's maybe really Queen
takes
F7 Queen F6 Bishop
E5 sure how convincing that
is something like Ria check is not
leading to
much Queen F6 Bishop E5 is
there a way
to kill black here immediately
Bishop H6 Rook H6 Queen takes
H6 it's not winning that
clearly Queen F6 Bishop E5 this also
Rook takes
E5 Rook E5 Queen E5 Queen
takes d8
King F7 I'm not sure that I'm winning
easily
there
H so Queen F6 Bishop E5 is there another
great idea of course I can take H6
immediately Rook takes Queen takes Queen
takes um a king takes F7 is there maybe
a way
to to win
here
maybe winning the a rook F1 is still
very
strong yeah okay that's going to
win
H that's going to win yeah like Bishop
E5 Bishop H6 Rook H6 Queen H6 King F7
Rook F1 I was just a little bit in doubt
because it looks like there are so many
strong moves that threaten something
that it uh that it irritated me okay the
next one of course this is a move that
you would play instantly if if you have
like 5 seconds on the clock but I still
wanted to try to work it out okay then
the next
one oh that looks tricky on the eile
yeah immediately looking
tricky H
okay yeah I think Bishop takes D5 looks
like the strongest
move it is very uh straightforward
Bishop D5 Knight takes D3 Bishop B7 will
win simply A8 Rook hanging and Knight
hanging so that's too much um Bishop D5
Bishop takes D5 Knight takes D5 is also
winning the Knight cannot move because
E7 hangs and I'm threatening to take E7
and F3 so this is a
win yeah and now the Knight hangs and if
he goes F5 I can take E7 King E7 F3 and
that's it yeah the the typical situation
with the Rook on E1 being opposed to the
king that um is very often it's just
simply deadly if you cannot get out out
of the middle here and The Rook is
coming to the
eal
okay next one I'm playing Black all it
looks like need to defend properly
here um or
not
yeah you can give this check
here King F2 is there any great move
there I mean uh what is this actually we
have we have piece down here right M
okay but we can also give this check
this is in fact quite
nice now Queen D4 check Queen F2 there's
Rook E1 check Bishop F1 and then we just
take the rook and we are in exchange up
if we give the check and he goes King
H1 we have Rook E1 check Bishop F1 and
queen takes F7 so this is the
win yeah and now Rook E1 that's the move
that needs to be found uh or is there
something better probably not a win is a
win is a win
so here anything better than King takes
I guess not we just take the
rook and here we just have a winning end
game yeah we are an exchange up with the
D Pawn being a free pass pawn and we can
go Rook A1 harassing the queen side so
an easy easy
puzzle aha okay the AG file looks uh
looks
dramatic um
okay black has absolutely no counterplay
in this position which is very
important so I wonder um what exactly is
not working with why isn't Queen H6 just
winning Queen H6 it threatens Queen
takes H7 Checkmate if he goes King G8 we
take H7 king f8 queen h8 mate and in
addition yeah we are threatening Queen
f8 mate so there is no F6 move or
something like that so it's just a
win and M yeah that wasn't
difficult okay we need to defend here in
this
position um
okay yeah our King is in check and I
mean what alternatives do we have King
C1 Queen C2 M if we go to C3 there
is Queen C2 check at least Queen C2
check King
D4 Rook to d8 King to E5 Queen takes B2
that that looks totally
insane so Bishop E2 is the move that
really comes to mind first I
think H also not that
easy Bishop E2 yeah if he takes with the
pawn that's Queen G6 mate that's nice if
he takes with the
queen um Queen
E2
D2 Rook G1 check maybe King
F7
oh that it should win yeah E and F Pawn
are too strong so Bishop E2 it's mostly
about checks Queen F4 check or C3 check
as an intermediate move C3 check in fact
looks a bit tricky C3
check C3 chick
D B takes C3 Queen F4
check but King
E1 Queen G3 check there's a ton of
checks going
on huh
interesting Bishop E2 but Bishop E2 3 C3
check I can go to C1 actually yeah this
is
winning okay and if he goes Queen F4
check immediately I cannot go to C3
Queen
E5 Bishop E2 check Bishop E2 Queen F4
check Queen E1 Queen G3 check King F1
takes on E2 check queen king takes
E2 there's only Queen G2
check King E3 Queen G3 check Queen F3
Queen G5 check Queen F4 well that's long
long line wrong line yeah I have to do
that yeah I cannot run I have have to
play that anyway yeah
um yeah well this is this is rather easy
I thought Queen F4 was a little bit uh
more tricky but I'm I'm just escaping
there okay the next problem
please OHA
many many things here many um problems
here look like defensive ones but here
that's well this isn't this just check
and mate check here and the King has to
go to D5 and then B takes C6
Checkmate
yep okay so um very very easy one just
check check and made that's fun
okay
okay oh this looks
like we can do something here with
smothered made ideas like
that H do we have a Checkmate here in
even yeah I think we have the the thing
is that there's this uh funny oh funny
is the wrong word this is this mating
pattern of Anastasia mate quite a quite
a nice name for a ch maate um and this
is with the the Knight on E2 here yeah
it gives it takes away G3 and G1 and
what I can do is I can take
here yeah and now okay you have we have
a um a pedestrian way to win now with
Queen F1 oops sorry Queen F1 Queen F1
Knight G3 check using the pin king G1
Knight takes F1 and we have a winning
end game but we can also do
that and this is Anastasia mate the
Knight taking away G3 and um here is a
Pawn on G3 but taking away G1 and G3 and
queen H7 is the mate it's very good to
know those mating ideas those mating
patterns because you see things much
quicker if you have seen those typical
um ways to Checkmate the king okay next
one doing many problems uh this
time yeah this is in fact u a well-known
position from from King of born end game
it's something that um that I have
studied with students yeah why to play
and win I don't need to calculate I just
know the solution H6 is the winning move
this is uh this is quite nice you have
to set up the G6 breakthrough yeah so
like now if you go G6 and black takes
you actually promote the pawn you have
to start with H6 and not with G6 if you
go G6 takes H6 King F6 is right in the
in the in the in the Box yeah of the
pawn and stops the pawn so I have to go
H6 first and prepare that
breakthrough very
nice okay a that looks
dangerous so how are we going to going
to do that yeah it's it's about checks
Knight H6 check for example looks nice
King to h8 it's a it's pins all over the
place so black cannot take it King h8 we
take F7 with check yeah but there's a
better solution here Bishop takes F7 is
better yeah if King h8 then Queen H5 is
made and here we are giving this big
check on H6 which is either Checkmate
after king f8 queen F7 made or here we
are winning the
queen yeah so this is um very uh
straightforward thing it's much better
than playing Knight H6 um in the first
place
okay didn't I do that before I I have a
I remember that I did this did this
before and it irritated me to no end
okay H tons of tons of checks here which
is nice but still um a bit
irritating so Queen D2 Check Yes King D3
there's queen king F3 there's Queen D3
mate yeah so Queen D2 check King E4 and
then just F5 right I mean this isn't
that
difficult um or is there
some hidden hidden trick that I don't
see I don't think so is there something
better I mean okay winning the queen is
certainly enough but is there a
Checkmate
somewhere
um yeah there actually is yeah I can
give this check here King F3 and then
Queen D3 mate is even better than
F5 yeah I mean this is H not not not
so not so great that F5 is so easily
winning the queen but Checkmate is
Checkmate so this is always U preferred
than winning the
queen
okay oh that looks like that looks like
trouble Queen H6 made is the move that
you want to
play um but how exactly are we going to
manage
that H not so easy to get that
H Rook H4 is also an interesting try
trying to sacrifice on
H5
H wow I cannot really believe that there
is just one solution to
this Knight takes H5 is also I mean
looking very dangerous Knight H5 G H5
Queen H5 check King moves Rook G4 is
Checkmate in a couple of moves and after
Knight takes H5 what exactly is Black's
defense I'm threatening to go Knight F6
back
H that
looks completely crushed
in Rook
H4 Rook
H4 yeah maybe King G7 but still the
Knight takes H5 should win
this a it's really hard to believe that
this isn't like there are multiple ways
to do
it maybe there are some back rank issues
with Rook
H4 Queen B4 or
something I come on Knight takes H5
should win right yeah it does
win it really should
win um and here what are we doing here
Queen H4 yeah
probably or is there something
better cannot do with double checks Rook
E3 d takes e there's no M
now
Queen H4 looks good yeah with Queen F6
threatened
yep queen queen F6 Queen G7 Checkmate if
he takes Queen takes H5 King G7 Rook G4
check King F6 Queen G5 mate yeah quite
nice okay the next
one oh it looks like a very big attack
um yeah and we are using we we are using
the pin here of this bishop the bishop
on B3 is the star piece of this uh this
winning
sequence um I'm actually
wondering yeah Knight takes G6 he can
take the queen and then we have a
discovered check but no maid but Rook
takes uh
sorry
uh
oh wait wait wait wait I'm I'm I'm a bit
I'm a bit too quick
here H I thought I can just take
a take there ah okay it's Ah that's
actually a nice one yeah I was thinking
that there must be something like I mean
like Rook
G6 it's it's crazy I just had to totally
wrong idea it's about this pin of the F
Pawn Yeah and but taking on G6 is simply
not working because there's always the
queen hanging but we have a win here
with Queen H7 this is really nice has to
take check black can play the Desperado
on H4 it doesn't matter much and now
Knight G6 for Rook h8 check mate yeah
really nice yeah Rook h8 mate there's
always this bishop here it's uh pinning
the F Pawn so black cannot take the
Knight and Rook h88 is um Rook h8 made
is um unavoidable yeah so just uh just
very
nice okay next
one oh waiting for the computer
move that
looks looks really weird black has some
strange offside pieces yeah
but where does the Queen actually go the
queen has no
Square
huh
or or
not it cannot go to E2 it's all covered
funny so we have to find some
justification here I mean or I have to
we have to find some way to uh to to
save the Save the Queen here or gain
some gain something for l the
Queen
H I don't see it at the moment
really also no counter
attack I mean what you can do is Queen
takes C3 Rook C3 Rook C3 and then the
Knight on A3 is trapped yeah this is a
trapped
piece yeah that's probably the solution
yeah there is really no other move Queen
C3 Rook C3 Rook C3 the Knight on A3 is a
attack that has no Square it can go to
C4 Knight takes C4 Queen C7 or something
but Bishop
F1 saves everything and white will
have white will have what what do I have
rook and two pieces yeah that will win
yeah Queen takes C3 is right I see no
other move all other squares are
protected and there are no I mean
counter attacks Vision Zs Bishop G5
Bishop B6 is ridiculous you have to do
that yeah and now A3 is trapped yeah
here we can take
and um it's too much yeah two pieces
white has Knight and Bishop and Rook
against Queen and uh also additional
problem is that Black's position is wide
open here the king is very weak so
everything will will enter the pieces
will enter the the black
position
okay is this one of those those race
situations H okay
okay it's not that difficult actually
okay we want to play A7 um and I mean we
probably will play A7 but um the the key
problem is the bishop that will go to G2
to stop the pawns if we go A7 Bishop G2
we have Knight C2 check and um this is a
problem Knight C2 check oh wait um let
me think about it Knight C2 check
King D3 there's Knight E1 for fork but
there is
also there
also King to
E5 I I have to start with Knight C2 I
have to start with the check if I start
with the check check King
E5 I have Knight
E1 Bishop F5 Knight F3 check King on a
light square and then I'm promoting yeah
so I have to start with this
move that's important and now the point
is if I go A7 Bishop G2 saves the day
but I can start with Knight E1 I'm
covering in G2 so I'm just threatening
A7 the only way for him to get to a
light Square on the long diagonal is
Bishop to
F5 it's the only move and now I can give
the check on F3 after which a yeah this
is this was a bit
sloppy
um this was sloppy
play uh can go to F6
still
but okay it's still it's still a winner
here King F6 Bishop
D2 uh Bishop D2 Knight D2 Knight D2 then
he has to go to H3 and then I give check
on e4 and then I'm promoting that's
funny I didn't I only I worked it out
step by step yeah
check King moves and
then we are doing the doing the home run
funny yeah okay it was um a little bit
like cheating yeah I did it step by step
it's better if you calculate it all the
way through but it it it must it needed
to it must be something like that so I
put it on the board quite nice problem
to to stop the Bishop from um yeah
preventing the pawn from
promotion okay a final one to make it a
oh that's actually a repeat we had this
before so um what was this solution
again like this it sometimes happen that
the same puzzle is is coming up
again and this we also had come on guys
this is
weird at least this is quickly
done I want one
more
okay how are we going to
checkmate here
h Huh okay well they have to check
various combinations here of of uh
sacrifices on H2 and on G3 of course
there's also coun to play Queen takes D5
check that needs to be needs to be
looked at
actually nice yeah Queen takes G3 is
winning
here Queen takes G3 is
winning the reason is I can put it on
the board yeah this is winning if he
recaptures with the Rook I'm playing
Rook H2 check King G1 Rook H1 mate
taking with the F Pawn is Rook takes H2
mate so he only has Queen takes
D5 I have to catch capture there is no
alternative and now if he captures with
the Rook I take D1 so he has to take
with a pawn and now the big point is
that even this is a
Checkmate that's really nice yeah it's
even a checkmate with this um yeah with
this reduced material when those Queen
takes D5 is actually a queen trade but
still we are checkmating white here
though so quite a nice puzzle yeah I
hope you enjoyed this tactics trainer
session about 30 minutes of quick
tactics I hope you you solved a couple
of um the puzzles yourself while I was
uh going at it you can always pause the
video a little bit if if you like to
look at the positions a little more okay
thanks for
watching